-Guys, as I mentioned,
it is Nana Week
here at the show,
and we've been giving some love
to all the grandmas out there,
all the gammies,
all the meemaws,
the bubbies, yeah, the abuelas.
Every night this week,
we've been shining
a spotlight on
a talented grandma.
Tonight's talented nana is
Debbie Bazza.
She is from the Bronx, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she's gonna do some
stand-up comedy for us tonight.
So without further ado,
ladies and gentlemen,
give a warm welcome to
Debbie Bazza!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, everybody.
I'm so happy to be here
with all of you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm married 30 years.
It took three husbands,
but it's still 30 years.
Wow! What a
great-looking audience.
Do I look okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you. It's a lot of work.
Between the creams,
moisturizers, and lotions,
I got into bed last night,
slid right on the floor.
My two grown daughters
moved back home.
That crap shouldn't be allowed.
They were always fighting
and screaming growing up.
One morning,
they're beating each other up
over the last pair of
school socks.
I'm trying to open my eyes
and drink my coffee.
I walked out of the room.
I figure,
let the stronger one live.
I don't care.
And they would threaten me.
"I'm running away.
I'm gonna run away."
So, I would reassure them
and tell them,
"Honey, you don't have
to run away.
I'll get the car and take you
wherever you want to go."
Do me a favor --
take your sister with you.
I like my own room.
Your father's snoring
is keeping me up all night."
Isn't that the worst,
trying to sleep with a snorer?
You've got that little window in
between "kuhhh!" and "kehhh!"
to fall asleep.
He tried.
He got the no-snore tape and
the no-snore spray.
He even got a no-snore pillow.
It kind of works if you put it
on his face and...
I just want to say
I love my daughters
and I'd do anything for them.
Maybe I'd do
a little more for one,
but, basically,
I'd do anything for them.
You've been a great audience.
Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
You were phenomenal.
Thank you so much!
Come on! Debbie Bazza!
-Jimmy!
-Debbie Bazza!
-Oh, my God! Jimmy Fallon!
-That was Fantastic!
Oh, my God!
-Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-And thank you
for signing my book.
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, oh.
-I'll sign your book.
Whatever you want, I'll do it.
-Yes, that -- Oh, my God.
-Are you kidding me?
That snoring bit was fantastic.
I loved it.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Give it up for Debbie Bazza,
everybody.